fidelity the multi-trillion dollar asset
manager is all in on bitcoin it just
recently was announced that fidelity has
been buying and mining bitcoin since
2014. that's right one of the largest
asset managers in the world is not only
stacking sats but they've actually been
mining it now for years ultimately this
revelation came from christine sadler
christine came over to fidelity to run
their new digital assets division a
couple years ago she is now the head of
sales and marketing at fidelity for
digital assets she came in 2019 from
coinbase and that new digital assets
division she has overseen both the
launch and the growth of that inside of
fidelity now fidelity continues to be
super super super bullish on bitcoin why
they released reports saying that
bitcoin could be worth over a million
dollars before the end of this decade it
also could be worth a whopping 100
million dollars by 2035. that's insanity
they declared bitcoin to be superior
money and in august they bought over
seven percent of the largest bitcoin
mining firm in the world in marathon
digital now it's fascinating to not only
see one of the largest asset managers in
the world be so bullish but to be
talking about million dollar bitcoin
prices and also to be putting their
money where their mouth is buying so
much of some of these firms we've got
this quote here which says that quote no
other digital asset is likely to improve
upon bitcoin as a monetary good because
bitcoin is the most relative to other
digital assets secure decentralized
sound digital money and any improvement
will inevitably involve trade-offs not
only is fidelity have a lot of assets
under management not only does fidelity
appear to actually understand bitcoin
but you have to give them kudos for
having the courage and the conviction to
publish their thoughts
to talk about this openly to publish
reports to the institutional investor
crowd fidelity is all in on bitcoin
fidelity is stacking sats fidelity is
also mining bitcoin and fidelity is
buying up ownership in other bitcoin
related companies fidelity understands
where the world is going and fidelity
doesn't want to be left behind kudos to
fidelity because fidelity is a bitcoin
first company now and the second that
they realized bitcoin was good for
business they went all in